story here and this one I haven't
actually read yet but let's uh let's
talk pop culture birds of prey dead in
the water so most of you are probably
aware of the new birds of prey film
that's gonna be coming out soon it's
Harley Quinn DC Universe I we had to
talk about this because Adams said
something to me that made me laugh yeah
it's an offshoot of an offshoot that's I
think that's but that wasn't what was
funny you were like oh is that a real
movie oh no we were we were at the we
were at Best Buy and I saw I saw an ad
and I'm like oh great straight-to-dvd
yeah yeah i straight-up thought it was
straight-to-dvd boo because it just
feels like that kind of a movie and
there sure enough here we see it's like
it's dead in the water
it's gonna go right to DVD I don't know
it's gonna happen but so so I did a
segment on this on my second channel my
Tim Cass news channel basically nobody's
buying tickets
there was a story that came out where
this writer I think it's the guy from
cosmic book news Matt McGloin and he
checked a bunch of presale tickets for
birds of prey which is essentially -
it's basically Suicide Squad part - I
don't know no it's it's a isn't it just
her no it's her and a bunch of like
female Boylan's and but it's not Suicide
Squad though no it's not right I'm just
saying it's like basically following up
after that right what are they doing
they have no idea what they're doing
with these movies yeah so apparently
this is like the reviews were apparently
good but no one's buying presale tickets
I checked the local theater nearby and
guess what it's not playing
it was hope no it is but it was open
like I said wherever I want oh is it out
already
no pretty sell tickets Oh and so when
1917 came out I could not go see it cuz
it was what to pack yeah I was sold out
and we were and so we wanted to go see
it like the the Sunday or whatever yeah
opening weekend and it was packed birds
of prey that's all good
you're good you know you want to watch
you watch the Norton you know the strong
woman's you know is that is that what it
is you think I don't know you know
ghostbusters four right exactly so
Ghostbusters 2016 I think they're just
bad movies because I feel like it wasn't
look you know oceans eight do you ever
see that yeah like part four of the
ocean series where all the characters
were female now they made a bunch of
money it was it wasn't actually as bad
as I thought it might be it was okay
yeah it was like Ocean's Twelve Oh
which was but it was like not very good
how corny is it where it's like the main
character is the cousin of Danny ocean
and she's a criminal too like you are
trying so hard why don't just make a new
movie yeah yeah why name why keep it oh
sure why not but so cool like there was
a they had a good cast so well you've
seen that you seen the trailer for birds
of prey I haven't even seen the trailer
right now but you just based on the ad
you are like you thought it was a
made-for-tv like WB movie what you know
you see the cardboard box and I'm like
oh cool like should we pick up a copy
here watch it oh yeah instantly just
assumed it was the DVDs were sitting
there but it was just an ad they were
like trying to promote it in Best Buy
which is this this uh this site cosmic
book news says that they have I think
they have a source claiming that it's
dead in the water so let's let's read
little bit about this and you know the
main reason I wanted to do this is
because you just saw Joker I'm at what a
killer me I saw I saw Joker oh my
opening night preview night but let's
work with Joker woohoo now that's a good
option well no that's a standalone
well it is it is you're right but let's
what Joker came from Batman so right
technically right so they it was like a
unique adaptation right we're spinning
so fast me let's uh let's read the story
cosmic news says following my articles
about birds of prey tickets not selling
I've just been contacted by a source in
Los Angeles that says the flick is quote
dead in the water while we simply have
to check the online ticketing apps such
as Fandango and Adam to see that no one
is behind tickets a source close to the
movie theater industry in LA fills me in
that there really are no tickets being
sold for birds of prey quote all the
local theaters are dead in the water
with presale tickets The Insider said
the insider says who is connected to one
of the largest theater chains in the Los
Angeles area the insider' insider goes
on to note that just as I and other fans
have done checking screenings reveals
there are literally showings with zero
ticket sold nah I didn't see that thing
the what I saw had like I think I saw
made
eight seats sold okay on uh on like it
was it was I think a day after the
pre-sale happened okay
that surprised me just eight it's a
comic book movie like even if it's bad
like the the the the DC movies they're
bad but they still go see it that bad
right right right they're entertaining
you know like people panned a lot of
these movies but they still go and see
them yeah but this I don't know what it
is I mean what is there definitely akyuu
know you think about it like who's
reading who's going and watching it's
like probably teenage boys or like
people like us you know topic but no
look at you know that Charlie's Angels
reboot they did know I think one of the
problems is they're trying to take
properties that were originally made for
young men you know and teenage new
teenage boys uh-huh with like scantily
clad women right but then turning them
into like strong women's like strong
female and as we know from the
mandalorian memes what Disney thought
women wanted was the fierce fighting ray
and what they really wanted was space
baby baby Yoda I the joke
okay it's like I wanna like you know
it's space babe but it's true
no no no hold on hold on but they I mean
they did they love the space baby it's
true like man they went nuts for that
Murch well let's be real okay Hunger
Games does fine
among all Democrat you know it was it
was a it was a hit Wonder Woman did
great
it's possible to do a movie with the
strong female lead but whatever it is
they're doing with like Ghostbusters and
birds of prey nobody wants to watch it
but why why but why did they go see
oceans eight but they don't want to see
birds of prey did they go see oceans
eight though it made triple its money it
was like a seventy million dollar budget
made two hundred seventy million dollars
yeah yeah and there and the Rotten
Tomatoes from audience and critics I
think we're okay it was that bad so what
is it are they just doing bad movies and
how would they know that this movie is
bad I don't know no I good that maybe
how do they even know it's weird because
I want to say it's this like attempt at
an ensemble woman cast going after the
man who's chasing him that's what it is
okay it's like
I guess I don't know what it's actually
about but you have the character black
mask and he's going after Harley Quinn
and all these other woman so they all
team up to go after him together
I don't you know it's like an inverse
Scott Pilgrim or something okay yeah I
don't know so I feel like that is
off-putting but there's something about
it that feels like a you know like a you
remember those old TV shows like Xena
and Hercules cabin Sorbo where they were
like really kind of low-quality
yeah I was cheesy that's what it feels
like cheeseball oh it feels like this is
the movie version of Xena nobody wants
to watch cheese balls though no I mean
people do like I got to be honest man
I'm actually more interested in watching
the the The CW's DC Universe as cheesy
as it is the arrowverse yeah then this
hmm but why I can't put my finger on it
what do you guys think what is it yeah I
don't know well with the oceans movies I
was wondering if it was the gap between
the movies because the ocean's 11 came
out in 2001 and then seven years later
17 years later I get this one yes yeah
but does it make sense I mean this is a
DC movie let's talk about how good Joker
was you'd think coming off Joker they'd
be like calm down to go see a DC movie
Joker's a masterpiece
it really is it's gonna like let me ask
you a question about let me let me ask
you a question about culture can you
name a song and you guys in the chat can
you name a song from our generation
we're in 50 years are gonna be like oh
man that song from 2013 think about
going back to the 70s no I came there
they're Bohemian Rhapsody exactly
everyone can sing it's legendary still
to the thing you know Freddie Mercury
playing two stadiums or look at like
Elton John's he's still around and he's
got songs that people are like that Wow
yeah what do we got from from the from
2000-2010
I can't I can't name a song I don't
listen to music from this era either we
have songs from the 90s so sorry I bring
this up because I feel like the Joker is
gonna be a film where in 20 or 30 years
they're gonna be alike you've gotta see
Joker it's a really old movie from 20 it
was a twenty nineteen when I came out
people to be like I don't want to see a
2019 movie they don't even have you know
immersive virtual yeah right automated
reality
but it's really good like I hate
watching old movies cuz they're kind of
like corny and like bad CGI and right I
mean lack of see Jack's talking about
Tron but Joker no CGI well maybe you
know just a character-driven real story
that's exactly I was it felt like a good
just you feel for him by the end of the
movie you're not even upset at what he
did I mean you know scared by it but you
I'm scared like but you're like I get a
hand
I get why dude was amazing house I was I
was literally haven't seen the movie
go watch the gym I think everybody
goodness it is so good so I'm wondering
if anybody so so here's here's the
thought I had and I you know Paul Joseph
Watson talked about this but I've talked
about it a lot too
culture has stagnated think about
Christmas music when was the last time a
Christmas song like a legit Christmas
song became like a classic and was
played every single no it's Mariah
Carey's right I think that 1992 she's at
that really 92 92 but think about this
before that we have songs from the 50s
yeah and I was thinking to myself I'm
like do like isn't Jingle Bell Rock like
wasn't that new at some point and people
were like listen to this new song and
they put on Jingle Bell Rock now it's
like every single year the same music
over and why why haven't we moved past
why can't we do new things have we
staggered at that point where we're
regurgitating old comic books yeah well
I was you know it's funny actually I was
at my mom's house over the Christmas
time and train I think that the name of
the band did it a Christmas song and the
first time I heard it I was like ah what
is this POS like song oh yeah
it's not it's not Christmas and then by
the by the 50th time I heard it it was I
was singing along and I'm like Oz
Christmas is gonna become a classic are
we gonna I don't know I'm not I'm not
saying it's on that caliber but but I
just I feel like you at least good I
feel like you know what movies are
becoming derivative of derivatives
birds of prey there's so birds of prey
is basically just like well we were to
comic a really long time ago with made a
cartoon in a really long time ago we're
gonna make movie about it now yeah yeah
and it's just like and this has been
talked about its adaptation after
adaptation you know what some when was
the last
Hogg day movie made like a movie as good
as Groundhog Day that had no like
explosions and it was just like a it's
like weird wonky
we got edge of tomorrow which was fun
yeah that was like what it was like fast
the Furious meets Groundhog Day
basically yeah I feel like liked it
that's the thing about the Joker about
Joker the film is that it really does
feel like the kind of movie that was
really well made back in the 80s and 90s
that we can like think of like Groundhog
Day where did it feel like a film did
feel like a classic yeah you know I
think one of the problems with movies is
to like why the new Star Wars isn't fun
what people don't seem to realize is
that the original Star Wars films was
like the first time anyone ever saw
spaceships fighting on screen and so it
was like you go to the theater and
that's where you get to see well we see
it all day every day with video games
movies so when you do a new Star Wars
you see a giant ship you're like so what
it's like literally every movie I've
ever seen
Starkiller base Wow oh it's a bigger
than haven't seen that one before and
and so it's like what were they going to
I think George Lucas was talking about
this they're not actually doing things
you know they're not progressing it
right that we've stagnated so you look
at where we were before Star Wars and
then they were like we're gonna do a
film that puts you in outer space with
spaceships fighting people never seen
this before okay so they've seen some of
it before because obviously there was a
sci-fi stuff before this and there was
the shows from the 60s but this is like
one of the theater and seeing
lightsabers like this was like a new
thing and it was like yeah I was talking
to some it was a long time ago I was at
a friend's house and he had his dad had
a bunch of Star Wars stuff and this was
around the time of like the prequels
okay and I would you know we were
talking about Star Wars and I got to the
point where he was like I'm not a fan of
the prequels but I understand why
they're doing what they're doing it's
like kids today want like fast action
and superpowers and heroes and so you
know the original wasn't wasn't really
like that that's what he said to me he
was like you know when I was younger we
didn't really have a whole lot like you
guys have today so for us like seeing a
movie like this was a it was kind of new
and it was a big deal and the sequels
were like years later yeah the first one
came out and it was it and then like you
know what was like two or three years
later they do the next one and then it
was like three years later the next one
now it's like say
months later get the next Marvel movie
yeah a year later we get the next Star
Wars every year a Star Wars movie yeah
look at all the Marvel movies it's like
there's so many I love movies though I
do too I love them they're great and but
non-stop you know it's like and then the
next one and then everyone waits till
the end of the credits to see a little
bit of the next one you know and then
yes constantly there so I don't I don't
I don't know you know I want it I wanted
to say like I think birds of prey is
like dead in the water because nobody
wants to see this like strong woman's
kind of thing like you can do a show a
movie with a female hero
I like the Captain Marvel you didn't
like that I did not like it the wrong
but I liked it I thought it was like it
was cool how that was forced made no
sense like it was really like and that's
surprising too because Marvel movies I
think tend to be pretty good even when
they're like not that great
like Emma and the wasp is okay I feel
like I need to watch it again I I just
saw that recently again that's a good
movie - I like that one there was just -
like it was so it was so heavy-handed
with Captain Marvel I gotta watch it
again and maybe with new eyes cuz when I
first saw it I like to but I hear good
things about birds of prey like
apparently the screenings the screenings
were early screenings were good and and
you know but for you know and maybe
maybe it just looks like you know like
Hercules or Xena yeah that's what I kind
of feel when I see it I'm like this does
not look like a good movie you know yeah
all right well let's wrap that one up
cool we got a couple more segments
perhaps
you